this week on quadriga Greek to you new
start for Europe the eurozone leaders
summit that ended on Monday after a
night of tough negotiations paved the
way for a new Greek bailout a Greek exit
from the eurozone seemed to have been
averted but the conditions imposed on
Greece harsh forcing it to relinquish
sovereignty in key areas Prime Minister
Alexis tsipras said he'd been forced to
accept a bad deal have the months of
bitter wrangling irreparably damaged the
euro project or does the crisis offer an
opportunity for a reform of the eurozone
coming to you from Berlin quadriga the
international debate your host this week
john barrack and welcome to quad Riga
the EU has already had two stabs at
solving the Greek crisis and both have
failed now has the Greek crisis become
too large to fail too large for the Erie
you simply ignore it it has to find a
solution well maybe and paradoxically
could that be a start a new start for
Europe my guest today first of all Alan
Posner british-born author and political
commentator who writes for the German
newspaper d built and Alan says a new
start in Europe would mean scrapping the
euro unfortunately Europe's elites he
added had become addicted to us hey Kara
BTW germany correspondent for the Athens
news agency and greases alpha TV she
says the Greek case has proven that
Europe can achieve compromises but is
not yet mature enough for self criticism
and third member on the panel today is
the well-known correspondent that
well-known journalist and a political
writer or the love iden felt she
describes the e use management of the
euro crisis as muddling along at all
costs first of all Alan I'd like to
begin with you say here is telling us
that this was a compromise well it
looked to me like unconditional
surrender what do you think yes I see
that it definitely was I mean they
basically hauled mr. tsipras across a
log after he'd got a no vote for the
last conditions and dictated the
conditions to him again and then he had
to say yes and this has been a company
this is the thing that's so worrying
accompanied in Germany with a storm of
anti Greek feeling and patriotic sort of
upwelling of feeling our money thrown
into a bottomless pit and so on and so
forth and in the rest of Europe with a
lot of anti-german feeling understand
would but also very dangerous which is
why I think that as you asked I think or
I think it's created such bad blood in
Europe that it's is ruin the project
already hey you seem to be more
optimistic about it you at least say
that you believe that the shows that it
a compromise is possible they're been to
compromises in the past though two
bailouts that have failed what makes you
think that this is a compromise that
might work not much actually so this
might have been a compromise at least on
paper but we it remains to be seen
whether it can actually function we
still need at least four weeks of very
difficult negotiations to achieve a new
program within the ESM this is not going
to be very easy the German government
has actually stated that very clear even
today the debt sustainability is going
to be a big issue throughout this for
weeks Greek government is is demanding
haircut they're not going to take
yes it was saying that that he doesn't
think it will work he presented it to
Parliament and said at the same time I
don't believe this will work yes which
causes of course a big problem regarding
the program's ownership as we call it I
mean if the Greek government itself I
cannot support this program it's a it's
a very difficult program it's a very
difficult program on the Greek people if
the government itself cannot support it
how do you expect the people to accept
it and also the administration to
implement it because this is also a huge
issue in Greeks you can get some loss
through Parliament but the
implementation is a whole different
story yes Ozil avedon felt says it's
caused it muddling through isn't that
what economists usually do well probably
they do it usually but this is a crook
quite Andrew unusual situation so it is
out what we've seen the last weekend was
the agreement we will have a third
package but we don't have one at least
so they have to negotiate it they have
to have the next upcoming weeks a month
to build trust again in what terms
whatever so it is quite difficult
because as fais said it is not only
deciding on a program it is implementing
it it is the doing and there is as far
as I can see it no trust at all whether
they will do or whether they will
deliver well the ex greek Finance
Minister vara Farkas who sometimes uses
very colorful language as we know said
he compared it to kicking a can down the
road for as long as possible would you
agree with him yes I think so i think
he's right at this point at least so i
hate to find you agreeing with the
epithet what happened it was a long
night of negotiations and just at a
point where most of us thought that
agreement wouldn't be reached the
european union came out with well what
some people call a deal
they finally did it after a 17-hour
negotiating marathon eurozone leaders
came to an agreement on the Greek debt
crisis monday's summit results are being
celebrated as a victory for europe
hammering out a compromise between 19
countries with their conflicting
interests certainly wasn't child's play
but the german chancellor managed to get
them all in line exhausted but relieved
or at least a little with the specter of
grexit banished for the moment and
greece set to stay in the eurozone
europe showed that it is capable of
action even in tough times
Wars lividans felt muddling through you
were saying as describing this process
of trying to solve the Greek crisis is
it really muddling through or is it
simply a question of local interests
people fighting for their own local
interest the Germans fighting for the
Germans the Greeks fighting of the
Greeks isn't that the problem I can't
leave Thank I can't see sees that
because I think that at least you're you
have tried to stand together to get the
problem solved I'm not so um III don't
think that this is the right way to
solve it but the austerity Chancellor
the austerity Chancellor of course as
Allen was saying earlier had the German
media breathing down her neck saying
don't give in to him don't give a cent
to the to the to the Greeks and she's
she's getting face elections even her
own coalition partner who had supposedly
left politically left of her we're out
doing her in their in their demand
through austerity wasn't she also
playing a local German political game
well everybody has to plague local game
because you need the yes of your
Parliament's to get the package not only
decided but to get it through the
Parliament and for things like that but
I think that um it is not fair to to
play the ball to Europe to the to the
other euro countries interceptor to say
they they have a second to get a gin and
they are playing only for their own
popular population I think they won't do
if they would do if they did do that
they just had voted for grexit last
weekend but isn't this a problem Alan I
come back to it I'm gonna insist on this
is a problem in Europe and has been a
problem all along with with all kinds of
other issues like the agricultural
policy that cannot be reformed it seems
that that that there is not a common
European vision there are people who
come together and they come together to
get the best deal for their own country
out of it we're seeing it with a British
at the moment well this is fine within
the European Union this is the way your
opinion works the problem is the Euro
doesn't but the problem is you
if you have a single currency without a
single state without a single dead
without a sync without democratically
elected government which which has which
is responsible to a to an electorate
about economic policy then you're going
to have the problems that we have now
again and again and again because the
Euro divides Europe it makes Germany
more competitive visa vie everyone else
basically in the whole of the eurozone
but especially Greece Spain Portugal
France and and France is going to be a
big problem so you can't have a single
currency without some kind of political
union and no one in Europe want that
least of all the Germans and this is why
this is going to fail this is why
kicking the can down the road means the
next crisis is Spain or France and there
we won't be able to talk about us brexit
or afrik sit this is going to be the end
of the euro and people don't seem to be
understanding this out but outside the
eurozone people see this fairly clearly
well isn't this partly FA because
European leaders are failing they're
failing in communicating this to their
own people and doing it perhaps for
their own short-term political themes
yes actually we've talked about it a lot
here as well the lack of leadership in
Europe everywhere in Europe also the
lack of political personnel in Greece as
well is a huge problem from you for
Europe today also in the beginning of
the crisis nobody had any idea about
what to do how to deal with this crisis
and five years down the road we're still
struggling with the basics of the crisis
the Euro or not the euro I mean these
issues should have been solved a long
time ago but but but only in Greece the
other countries Spain Portugal Ireland
they are quite better off now so it's so
though is it really so it is so yes of
course they do they have an employment
instance but they have but what the baby
moving in
employment traditionally comes after the
turnaround of economy it takes half a
year a year before employment picks up
after recession like Spain had had the
years it goes so this is a lost
generation everybody is saying it's
twenty-five percent of young people and
spent in in in Greece you've got two
fifty percent of young people unemployed
how can this possibly be turned around
in a capital of years well I think if if
you if you look at unemployment of young
people you do have lots of reasons for
that but it's not only economy and that
is not only the recession our turnaround
of economy that has a lot to do with how
do you treat elder elder elder people in
their jobs will they be able to to leave
the jobs will won't they be a believer
time yes not only only early retirement
but but also the question would you just
if you are 50 or 55 would you just go
for another job would you leave your job
and to go to go for another job if there
is a good offer if in their lot of
countries in Europe well you won't do
that because you're not secure that you
will be successful you even there is no
opportunity to to make people Gill and
therefore young people won't be able to
just come in two jobs to come into a
sufficient life and that that is one
there is only one of the reasons but
there are lots of reasons why young
people are not do not have the chances
they should have Allen is itching to
disagree with you I can see he's making
it this is all very well and no I'm
don't disagree of obviously labor market
has to be deregulated to enable a you
know people to get in jobs and leave
jobs and so on but just take the big of
you look at growth rates in the world
look at the growth rate in America in
the United States of America look at the
growth rate in Great Britain look at the
growth rate in Poland all countries
which don't have the Euro have a higher
growth rate than the eurozone has the
only country with a with a with a
minimal growth rate within the eurozone
is Germany and they're very proud of 1.1
percent which is terrible terrible so
eurozone is the problem
and there and they're not kicking the
can down the road actually they're
kicking the Greeks for their own
problems the fact they've created an
uncompetitive zone in the middle of
Europe which is killing itself no they
don't i think i think you're right what
the what the perspectives of the euro
are so i'm not sure whether this is a
model we will talk about the next we
will talk about it 10 years ahead but i
think my mother but i think that um if
it comes to europe and if it comes to
the perspectives of offer of africa of a
common economy space or of a common
economy there are lots of chances and
opportunities and you are not better off
if you are not a member of the EU you
are better Oh eurozone but but even the
eurozone look at the Baltic States look
at UM the Netherlands for example of
Austria that these are success stories
look at Ireland for four years and years
and years oh it's pain right now they
have the fastest economy growth in in
within Europe but there is in all these
countries also there is still the
problem of unemployment and youth
unemployment remains a huge problem it
does seem to me fais I will ask you
about this does seem to me that there's
a lot of talk about figures and about
from an economic point of view that
actually leaves the human being out of
the center of what it economics is about
how concretely do people in Greece
actually feel about the situation I mean
we we see pictures quite often that on
that are not that already quite
surprising because it seems the life is
quite normally in Greece in many ways
what the pictures that we see in Germany
but when I read for example that the
lowest pension in in Greece is 300 euros
a month and these pensioners are also
supporting sometimes members of the
family are unemployed that suggests a
different picture what's your sense of
the real atmosphere in Greece I can give
you an example my father used to take
like 700 years his pension was 700 years
after 45 years of work in Greece and
this was before the crisis so the whole
picture that he has been prison
and in the international media that
Greeks are lazy people who just sit
around and retire the 50s in their 50s
or and take 2,500 years a month as a
pension these are not true and you can
also see pictures which are really
disturbing these days and Greeks have
the feeling that there is a distinct
vengeful element in Beijing new
agreement exactly that if Europeans do
not trust the Greek government or mr.
tsipras himself this is a whole
different story but this is the the
people we're paying now and the people
are going to pay in in the next year's
but for me and this is just to pick up
on something that also has said before
the the difference between Greece and
these other countries you talked about
is that Greece's problem was I mean
Greece is not a poor country but Greece
doesn't have the institution's we needed
institutions nobody saw that in the
beginning doesn't either forms and antic
reforms yes I think we realize that is
that there is also a problem of
leadership in Greece itself there's been
a problem leadership we agree I have
suggested that there is also a problem
of leadership in Europe as a whole I
think we are also somewhat agreed about
that you have your reservations at the
last week and we thought that some kind
of leadership with between angular Makka
Francois Hollande they they didn't agree
on each point but at the end at the end
of the night there were 19 19 votes in
within the Eurogroup in favor of a third
package and in favor of of a reform and
I think this is in some perspective an
expression of leadership in Europe which
has it should be respected well it's a
truism in Europe for many people that
you're a functions best or the EU when
Germany and France agree and have the UK
as a kind of counterweight
that is certainly not the case the
moment is it a Germany has really the
power in its hands because of its
economic superiority and perhaps that is
one of the problems as some people at
least think let's look at a report on
the leadership question the euro has
been an economic motor for Germany it
has enabled German goods to be exported
cheap fling which has given the German
economy a long-awaited boost for weaker
economies that's become more and more of
a problem Germany's economic strength
has made it a dominant force in yerevan
upsetting the political equilibrium in
the EU in the Greek crisis negotiations
germany played the leading role but
Angela Merkel and her Finance Minister
Wolfgang Troy blur are viewed not only
in Greece but in the US and other
European countries as self-righteous and
uncompromising is Germany's dominance
threatening European unity
here's Germany's dominance threatening
European unity if you read the French
newspapers you get the impression don't
you that it was alarmed that save this
saved this marathon session in Brussels
that volkan cobbler and Angela Merkel
were prepared to accept a grexit but he
was the person who came forward with a
European idealism European Europe has to
has to continue on the path that it's on
that we're too far along there's no way
back now we need not less integration we
need more do you agree with that well I
think that um that that was not the
right answer that it's not the right the
right answer I thought that the best
thing we could say about the last
weekend was that everybody went home
home and was the winner of the of the
game so alexis tsipras went home and
said well that was the thing i could
achieve angular america and work on
sharply came back and everybody
respected them for just saying at one
time not there is no alternative but to
have an alternative which could be and
which which has been discussed and even
Francois Hollande who helped the Greek
to not only prepare their papers for the
summit but also just to bring it to to
land in the in the night to monday but
it seems it seems very uninspiring it
seems it seems you know one of the
reasons that we're told why Germans like
Angela Merkel is because she's such a
good manager but is it is Alan Posner
surely in a situation like this I don't
just mean Greece but the crisis that
this actually throws Europe and doing
the question about the future of Europe
we don't just need a manager we need
somebody who's charismatic we need a
vision we need to go forward in Europe
more integration says or long so for
example than than less integration well
yes it's all a world to say we need
someone charismatic but we don't have
anyone so let's face things as they are
I think the problem is not that mr.
shoigu for instance is not idealistic
enough he's very idealistic he wants an
integrated Europe
but he thinks it can only happen if your
book cites Germany so he wants all the
countries in the euro zone to be sort of
German and that's the real problem and
he's using the euro crisis to enforce
that he's trying to make grease into
little tooling in and it's not going
today no no it doesn't do that you got
exactly that you're the way you feel for
for leadership for years and years and
years everybody but if I wasn't wanted
Germany to to to show leadership not
only to pay for everything but but also
to to do touche politics just to be
present on the scene and and to show
leadership in some kind and now they're
doing it and it is not right anyway so
what should they do well it depends on
the kind of leadership doesn't it i mean
i remember in 2008 i think it was i was
a party convention see to your party
eventually convention in in stuttgart
where Angela Merkel made her famous
analogy of the of the perfect economist
when she said the answer is of course
what you should need you should ask the
the average German housewife who knows
that you can't permanently live beyond
your means isn't that rather than
impoverished view economic leadership is
not something you should can buy in a
retail shop so you have to take this
person's you have on the scene and if
they are not able to deliver something
different as you want to be leadership
persons they you have to live with what
they are able to do and able to deliver
hey ten years ago the controversial
American economics writer Jeremy Rifkin
wrote a book called the European dream
perhaps who knows where he compared
Europe very favorably with America with
the United States and he said what we
have here in Europe what he really
admired so much was a sense of
citizenship that extols the well-being
of the whole person and the community
rather than the dominant individual as
an America that was ten years ago do you
think we've lost that European dream
definitely I don't think people anywhere
in Europe not only in Greece feel
identify themselves as Europeans anymore
we are going back to
nationalizing of Europe and people are
turning against each other now
throughout Europe and this is is this
the real crisis to me yes because
combined with the lack of leadership
this can end to wear to what Allen calls
it is at the end of the eurozone at
least if not the EU as a you are a Greek
I don't need to tell you that the word
that the word crisis of course comes
from a Greek word and it's a it is the
word basically that means it to means to
judge to make a judgment doesn't it and
so that a crisis is always an
opportunity not only for something to
fail but also to make a choice in the
right direction so this is the question
we've also been looking at in this show
the question of is this a new start for
Europe let me make a quick round of
asking you that question again starting
with you as love edenfield is this a
chance for Europe for a new start that
is what work i'm sure i blow over says
he always said that europe only shaped
itself in crisis and that was that that
europe always was ready to just find the
point to turn around and to find a turn
around for the better way and i think in
some perspective I hope he's right Alan
are we seeing a game-changer here is
this at least the possibility for Europe
of a game change well if the Europeans
would listen not so much to Athens but
to London for inserting it would be
because what we need or become
isolationist don't need wife's minutes
listen we need this integration so very
very quickly in a couple of words is it
going to work or isn't it is Europe
going to survive the EU well it's not a
simple yes or no answer and I'm afraid
it all depends are unsure but we will
see and we remain hopeful goodbye watch
us again next week
you